and of course there's the mad king
killed by my uncle
would you like to see where the last
targaryens are buried are you sure lady
margery doesn't find all this a bit
macabre i know it's quite a righteous
grace
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon video in this video
i will be showing you exactly what
happened to rhonera targaryen some of
you may or may not remember this but it
was actually revealed during the third
season of game of thrones when joffrey
was given margaery a history lesson
about the life and death of many members
of house targaryen it's interesting how
he might have revealed exactly how house
of the dragon ends in a throwaway line
that many fans most likely don't
remember if you don't want to know what
will happen in house of the dragon i
would highly recommend shutting off this
video now although george rr martin did
write this in his novel many years ago
it still might ruin the show for some of
you who don't know
now another interesting thing is house
of the dragon might have already
foreshadowed this in their most recent
episode when we saw renera and damon
walking around the city at night notice
how they show a dragon unleashing its
fire right as the woman says do you want
to know your death
do you wish to know your death child
might have added this as a way to
symbolize how raniera's life would end
now for those of you who don't know
renera will die by the hands of her own
half-brother aegon the second of his
name we actually already met him already
he is the firstborn son of her father
viserys and her best friend alison
hightower right at the end of the dance
of the dragons rhaenyra will die when
aegon feeds her to his dragon sun fire
let me show you what joffrey said all
the way back in season 3 of game of
thrones
rhaenyra targaryen was murdered by her
brother or
rather his dragon it ate her while her
son watched
what's left of her is buried in the
crips right down there
it is kind of crazy to think how
rhaenyra or at least what was left of
her was right there instead of the red
keep during the whole run of game of
thrones unless you had already read
george rr martin's novels you would have
had no way of knowing she was there
assuming you had even heard of her name
before house of the dragon began another
thing i find very interesting is how
joffrey's actor jack gleason did the
narration for that scene in the dance of
the dragons history and lore video i
believe this was released all the way
back in season 7 with their dvd features
in that history and lore video he again
describes how ronira died i think they
did an amazing job by having him do the
narration for the scene because he
sounds like he actually enjoys it like
we all know the sadistic joffrey would
which is also exactly how you would
think aegon would sound as he's feeding
his half-sister to his dragon
ever defiant told her dear brother that
she'd hoped he was dead
after you aegon answered
then
sun fire
bathed her in a blast of flame
and devoured her in six bites
when her son watched
leaving the seventh and final bite her
lower leg
for the stranger
so as you all can see renera does not
have a happy ending this is game of
thrones after all and as we all know
very few will make it out of this alive
if you think this has a happy ending
you haven't been paying attention
[Music]
so
you